[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rebecca lowe the presenter of nbc sport
groups premier league coverage pre and
post match
the premier league live they have a
match uh today at two eastern
you have uh chelsea and brighton coming
up at two eastern good morning rebecca
how are you
dan patrick lovely to see you i'm very
well i will come third behind messi
and cristiano ronaldo any day of the
week now i would pass on messi because i
don't think he's a great interview so
you're
second on the list behind ronaldo i
appreciate that okay
i'll go above messy yeah no problem okay
let's say i'm a child
and you're going to explain the super
league to me
how would you do it oh my goodness what
a question okay i would explain
that currently in the premier league
there are 20 teams
and they always have been since it was
formed in the early 90s
six of those teams who have self-branded
themselves the big six
so we're talking manchester city
manchester united liverpool
arsenal tottenham and chelsea and yes
they are six
very big clubs and they tend to do
better than any other club in the
premier league
those big six have gotten together
rather secretly it has to be said
with some other very big clubs across
europe we're talking ac milan juventus
in italy inter milan barcelona real
madrid and spain
and there will be they are saying they
have signed a contract to create their
own
midweek european super league esl
is what they're calling themselves which
will take place they want it to start as
soon as possible in august
and it will take place midweek
throughout the season but it will let
those clubs still play in their domestic
leagues
in the uk or in france or in italy or in
spain
the problem with the situation is that
this is a ring fence league
this is for want of a better word an
americanized
league so once you're in you're in
you're never going to get out no matter
if you become
rubbish overnight you're in you're in
you can only go into it on the on on
the proviso you have an amazing one
season in your league but then you might
have to
lose it again you might have to go out
again the ones that found and actually
have created this league
can never fall out of it which means
they will get
very very rich um jp morgan is backing
this league as
thing stands they are viewed for around
over four billion pounds to share
between them
so when they get that rich and they go
back to their domestic league
the gap between the likes of united and
city and chelsea and liverpool
and then the likes of burnley crystal
palace and southampton will be bigger
than ever before
which will mean ultimately competition
disappears
out of the premier league and as pep
guardiola the manchester city manager
said this morning
it is not sport if it doesn't matter if
you lose and if these teams lose in this
european super league it doesn't matter
there's no relegation they stay forever
so there is a lot of controversy around
this um but that is it in a nutshell a
breakaway controversial league
when did this start when when did they
start forming this
well done i've got to tell you i
remember being a child in the uk i mean
you know not that long ago but
back in the late 80s and people were
talking about a super league a european
super league i mean there was even
talked about it
in 1964 in some of the newspapers in
england so
this has been rumbling for decades but
really we don't
know the full um disclosure of
how how this all took place because it's
happened so quickly it was announced on
sunday night
um out of the blue very late english
time
about 11 pm in england it shocked
everybody how quickly it's come
out so this has obviously been in the
works for quite some time
how do you uh how is this uh prevented
how do they how do they combat this
well at the moment the backlash if
anyone listening and watching this
has been on twitter recently i'm sure
they've seen it james corden even talked
about it last night on his late late
show
the backlash is overwhelming it's the
biggest story i've ever worked on in
nearly 20 years of being in this
industry
it's the biggest backlash i've ever seen
so how does it get combated well
rumors today that chelsea and manchester
city
are wobbling some of the top football
journalists in the uk are saying those
two clubs
did not realize the backlash would be so
big they're wobbling so one
or two of the clubs pulls out it will
probably crumble
um money obviously is a huge thing jp
morgan
are they okay with this bad pr if they
stay on board that's good for the
super league if they decide actually
don't really want our name associated
with something which is getting so much
criticism
that's a problem and then you've got the
fans and down the fans i've heard fans
over the last 24 hours
on shows like yours but in england
saying i've been a manchester united
supporter for 40 years
here's my season ticket i'm done with my
club and i'm not talking one fan
i'm talking thousands and only this
morning the grandson of bill shankly the
great liverpool manager the man that
really
is in every single sinew of that club
the grandson of bill shankly
has told liverpool football club remove
the statue of my grandfather from
outside anfield so
this ground swell plus the players have
come out and said they don't want it a
lot of them have
and managers like guardiola it's a huge
pushback
so i suppose somebody has to crumble at
some point
under this pressure or withstand it and
it's up to these big clubs whether or
not
these owners really want to go forward
with this i was also wondering about the
role that the american owners are going
to play in this
because they don't live there and you
know
you you're gonna have man united
liverpool
and the impact that they could have
removed from this
uh the the role that loyalty is gonna
play in all of this
is what the culture is very very
different dan you and i have talked
about this many times and we've talked
about relegation and the difference
between america and the uk and i think
that's something that really has to be
understood about
english football we're talking about
institutions like united like liverpool
john henry the glazer family
sam cronkite arsenal these clubs were
established over 120 years ago
and by local people for local towns and
for cities to keep the community close
and to do great things like we've seen
throughout the pandemic in
the community and i think over in this
country here in the united states
there perhaps quite isn't that link
between
huge clubs and their local communities
they haven't been around as long
they weren't created by local men local
working class men for working class fans
so the loyalty
that seeps through english football is
incomparable really to anything over
here so when you look at it from the
owner's point of view from the american
owner's point of view
i can see that that it's difficult to
understand
they don't understand why anybody would
have relegation why would anybody
threaten
a club's future but that's all part of
what makes english football so
beautiful because it's competitive it's
sporting merit
it's how good are you on the day and how
good can you be
can you really pull off this amazing
result against a huge team
and we see it all the time and that's
what makes the premier league in my view
and many others
the greatest league in the world in any
sport so
i think loyalty they may be coming up
against a bit of a surprise with this
backlash because the loyalty
is a huge part of this game and i think
also we have to look at ourselves as
well down because
15 years ago these clubs were owned by
fans and by local businessmen well they
sold out
they did sell out to american owners to
russian owners like roman abramovich at
chelsea and now
10 15 years on we're seeing that maybe
that was the reason why
these business owners wanted to buy
these clubs to maybe turn them into
these european superpowers so
you know a lot of things have gone wrong
over the years and a lot of people are
now looking at themselves so
i think loyalty and football people
laugh there isn't always a lot of it but
my goodness between fan and club
dan it's tribal and it's a religion
i haven't heard you this passionate
about i know you love your sport but
you're worried about your sport i'm
concerned
i'm concerned very much so i i
i feel that the pyramid of english
football in the uk again
something that i wouldn't expect anyone
in the states to understand but
it's not just the premier league dan i
think i've told you this before there
are four or five there are five
divisions
underneath that and they're all
professional and these are professional
players now the money from the premier
league trickles down to all of these
clubs
that make up the local towns and
villages in the uk and the worry down is
this
that if the six teams from the premier
league go into the european super league
and become
so rich the dream is over in the premier
league because the premier league
becomes
totally non-competitive because these
six will have so much money
that nobody could ever compete and then
they'll have
14 clubs in the premier league trying to
get into a champions league which won't
have any champions in it which means you
can finish eighth in the premier league
and get into the champions league
because these other six don't want any
part of the champions league and all of
a sudden the premier league becomes
non-competitive the broadcast
rights would be nowhere near the value
they are now and the money and the dream
doesn't trickle down to all these clubs
below which is the very essence of
english football so
my concern is that hasn't been thought
through and
we are yet of course to see the full
plan because we still haven't seen
exactly what these owners want let's get
the full plan
and carry on this conversation but it's
a passionate time we do need to be cool
heads and calm heads
there are rumors today that it might
crumble so let's see where it goes but
yeah i am concerned for the future of my
sport for sure
how can i help you need to spread the
word down i need to come on here every
single day
every day every day every day
patrick your five minutes or five
seconds of soccer or whatever it is to
do
20 seconds and i know i've got people
watching today who agree with me we need
more
conversations with dan patrick now you
know i've been watching some
documentaries i watched the one on leads
i watched uh sunderland until i die
right
just letting you know i support the
cause and i like the
relegated you know programs the you know
teams
is my question to you dan i know it
wouldn't work over in the u.s relegation
because you're far too down the line
certainly in the nfl there's no real
league underneath it but
the relegation promotion i mean that
does it not it adds so much doesn't it
you can understand
yes well you could do this in college
football let's say you took the top
20 programs and then you could get
you know two drop each year and then two
college football programs
go up then that would resonate with
people and they'd be like
whoa wait a minute that's costly and
that's what it is it's
devastating when you drop financially
when you are relegated
devastating of course it is people are
laid off it's terrible and that's
and this is what makes the drama of
football so
engaging and addictive and of course
in the states things are different and
it's done in a different way and i
wouldn't expect them to just bring in
relegation but my goodness it would make
it better
but i wouldn't expect that but over in
europe over in europe
it's something that can't change it's
been there for hundreds of years
and i think what people are scared of is
that what makes the game so beautiful
looks like at the moment is going to be
removed dan
and it doesn't help your team crystal
palace they still aren't any good
so none of this
none of this helps you right you never
know i mean if the top six finish in the
top six places and crystal palace were
to finish seventh
i mean basically we're champions
i'm okay with that uh it's great to talk
to you
keep your head up got a lot of time you
know for cooler heads smarter people to
uh
i i know you follow the money and
unfortunately when you follow the money
it it's going to lead to this but uh
hopefully it doesn't
uh thanks for joining us as always i'll
be back tomorrow of course
of course okay yes todd make sure you
book rebecca for tomorrow
confirmed all right thank you that's
rebecca lowe there's a uh
premier league match later on today it
is chelsea versus uh brighton